hello or into welcome to this video
playing with all the rain yeah long
history of games against this player
okay understand yes it's typical move
instantly style and let's see what
happens even this the decision gets gets
played immediately of course super far
reaching but anyway okay I'm not going
to start so early on with my ranting
against this player okay we'll see what
happens the queen e 8 is 2 color h5 he
has opened the G file here for me so
i'll see if i can and can do something
now that i wanted to play anyway and now
he has misplaced his Queen and so on
let's see Queen age 5 immediately maybe
let's go there
threatening bishop age three
yes not cesium pam boucher night h2 but
it looks that doesn't look very
attractive yeah against that i can
probably already sacrifice the way
White's pizzas are misplaced on c1 and
so on and it might work not completely
sure though might have to shoot you one
not stuff like that
various Bishop Bishop to d1 f3 that's 93
you okay I'll do it
every year is interesting you might be
able to play a 30 it looks ugly but
might work okay so here I'm going very
straight fashion here towards f3 ug 10
games 5
group c 10 page five looks looks like
winning and maybe yes Bishop f4 then
somehow holding
looks very strange but might be possible
okay i still have flu i don't have that
so let's take
I'm attacking attacking be three years
well and that this is I guess okay I
mean I'm also porn up one night night f5
actually threatened tonight geez know
what that doesn't certain that ok but 95
is ok ideas to take 93 every three rogue
f2 and it's over on h2
okay okay so look to f2 would be cool if
I get that in d5 ideas root g 2 ok so
let's just grab more stuff three pawns
in the end game that looks ok should
activate that g7 Bishop though
93 93
white resides okay yeah every summer
against this playoff losing one time
buddy place like instant moves anyway he
always makes those super far reaching
decisions instantly like taking him and
I mean this is a pretty important
decision do you want to take whatever
anyway he did so immediately and okay i
mean i think the actual problem is this
move because FYI it's something that I
want to play anyway so I'm happy to play
it in a situation where it's pieces are
completely misplaced here and the
question is if I should sacrifice now or
not I really wasn't sure I can also play
normal news the engine actually once
Bishop f5 and well no it gives d5
winning and interesting Oh sem that's
actually quite simple you have to to
drive that way and now you know you take
and this is probably a lot better as the
night is completely off it cannot help
in the defense this is the wind for
black already this is big the big threat
okay but i don't think this is bad f3
was an interesting move but key 5 is it
seems to be good the night doesn't have
many squares I am now I cannot go here
check and the night here that's from g8
well that's the size of attack okay you
went what did you do you and King edge
one in a playbook f-fire here i'm also
winning open fire and now f3 yeah it
took if he plays root g one there's book
h5 and that you cannot defend and see in
this line
and h2 collapses it's made already nitey
i'm just-just 22 cards up with a big
position I rookie 30 is also good but
again it's it's two pawns and and
absolutely zero zero compensation yeah
now after some sunlight move this check
93 yeah okay that was a I think okay
Whitney against a Wolverine using this
g6 line which is quite a decent sideline
okay thanks for watching